this is outrageous where are the armed
men who come in to take the protesters
away where are they this kind of
behavior is never tolerating in baraqua
you shout like that they put you in jail
right away
no trial no no nothing journalists we
have a special jail for journalists
you're stealing right to jail you're
playing music too loud right to jail
right away you're driving too fast jail
slow jail you're charging too high
prices for sweaters
glasses you write to jail you undercook
fish Believe It or Not jail you overcook
chicken also jail undercover you make an
appointment with the dentist and you
don't show up Believe It or Not jail
right away we have the best patients in
the world
because of jail
[Music]
hello I'm your new command and officer
Captain Seth dozerman my motto is simple
efficiency efficiency efficiency can
probably just say it once are you making
fun of my stutter oh uh tricked you I
don't have a stutter boom I've already
established my authority through my
amazing sense of humor well done sir
welcome to the nine nine I'm Sergeant
Terry Jeffers and I'm not interested I
have no use for people I find people
weird and confusing I Live My Life by
Numbers you see this watch it tells me
how many calories I burn at any time
question how many calories you think I
burned walking from there to there you
female closest to me oh uh
three three
try zero point eight num nuts I made
promises to my superiors that I most
certainly cannot keep that's why I need
you idiots to work twice as hard no no
strike that four times as hard no no
strike that I need you morons to work
eight times harder than you've ever
worked and your entire life
I'm having a heart attack
yeah I'm having a heart attack
get back to work get a doctor
CeCe we're having a barbecue tonight
you're welcome to come thanks maybe I
will
get the gun away from the dog hey hon
have you seen my hunting rifle last time
I saw it the dog had it what is wrong
with you people
[Applause]
I'm going to get into politics
I do believe in destiny and I know that
I should hate you but I can't
I love you
and I don't care what people say we were
meant to be in each other's lives
[Music]
you took me for frozen yogurt yeah so
that's when I decided that I wanted to
be an architect
don't worry about it no I am going to
worry about it let's go fix this
was bad too
uh come on let's go
are you kidding me
do you maybe just hate yogurt
oh really I got my goodness you know in
the end this walk only cost me like
fifty dollars
um it was worth it I will pay for dinner
that only seems fair so again your Alibi
is a mysterious stranger handed you the
gun made you put your prints on it
robbed the store and then hid the gun in
your underpants Well yeah if you say it
like that it don't sound believable oh
hey Captain did you get my report on the
Finley murder uh yeah looked it over
nice work good thanks Dad
why is everyone staring at me you just
called Captain hold dad he said thanks
Dad what no I didn't I said thanks man
do you see me as a father figure Peralta
no if anything I see you is a bother
figure because you're always bothering
me hey show your father some respect I
didn't call him Dad no no no no Jacob I
take it as a compliment it's not a big
deal I called Vivian mom once and she's
my fiance guys jump on that Boyle has
psychosexual issues old news but you
calling Hulk Daddy hey Daddy is not on
the table here but you did call him dead
dude you shut up you've done nothing but
lie since you got here all right all
right I was lying about the holdup but
the dad thing that happened
he admitted that his Alibi was a lie it
was a trap all part of my crazy devious
plan I believe you thank you son
you want to talk about it later over a
give him a catch
I'd like that I'm Kelly Larson I read
online about your time capsule and I'm
here to make a suggestion oh I'm sorry
we're not taking suggestions Twilight
books it's a beautifully told Saga
vampires werewolves and romance uh you
are the person that's been emailing me
about Twilight I thought you would be
younger
and a girl well I'm not I'm older and a
boy but I feel very strongly that these
should be included can I tell you why
sure Kelly have a seat awesome lead your
case thanks okay Christmas Eve 1973
author Stephanie Meyer name Morgan was
born in Hartford Connecticut oh you're
going all the way back to her birth okay
and combined they have sold more than a
hundred million copies worldwide
have you seen any of the Twilight movies
no I have not let me describe them to
you shot for shot movie number one
Twilight we slowly pan up over a Mossy
log to see a deer drinking crystal clear
water okay Kelly this time capsule isn't
just a barrel full of stuff that people
like it's about life in Pawnee at this
moment in time and there is nothing in
Twilight that is specific to Pawnee I
disagree okay that the town of Forks
Washington is exactly like Pawnee except
for the climate and the vampires I'm
sorry I have to say no I beg you to
reconsider and I'm gonna have to ask you
to leave and I'm gonna have to do this
I'm just sick of it I'm so tired of this
sitting I am so tired of the rat race
you gotta keep it down okay I gotta work
in the morning Mommy is looking very
strong tonight
come on fine 20 across the board
yeah you gotta talk to your landlord
about that rat race that is my landlord
yeah
maybe I just need to go out of town for
a little while looks like an idea
Vermont is always nice for the Bahamas
I was thinking of Cleveland
that is also a place yeah I just haven't
been home in a long time we need to
search your bag
of course they do
I dream about moving back to Lakewood or
maybe even Shaker Heights
Big Creek Parkway it's in the kids the
St John Bosco's you know
maybe even cheering on the tribe at the
Jake this dream this is way down the
road right yeah yeah three maybe four
years
it's the sponge all right that's it
show's over okay that's
so how long do you see yourself living
in New York like forever at least I did
really
you want to end up like that
no I'm gonna be like her oh there is
nothing like New York in the spring
all right
come on this is the capital of the world
the culture
are you all right
now let me have a look at this Marvel of
American industry
good God
this doesn't look like the Prototype
looks more like the Prototype than most
things in this world how could this
happen the one in my office was perfect
well we didn't make the Prototype we
bought it in West Elm besides you whom
do I fire for this I don't know you I
mean you're the one who insisted on
hiring American Engineers all they teach
us now is how to build roller coasters
and Survivor challenges this is what
we've been making for the past month we
have ten thousand of these I would know
I'm not a math guy really
this is only a setback I just have to
create a market for terrible couches
besides what did Theodore Bazooka Joe do
when his eccentric millionaire father
left him nothing but a tiny pink rock
quarry he baked those rocks and sold
them to children
come
foreign